now from one thousand dollars all the
way up to twenty thousand dollars this
is what migrants are willing to pay to
smugglers and cartels to get to the
united states as i mentioned we went
into reynosa mexico on wednesday we
talked to a smuggler who rarely ever
talks to media and he walked us through
the migrants journey watch
[Music]
just to cross over to mccollum from here
it's a thousand and five hundred dollars
to two thousand dollars
if you want to go to houston it's
another cost and it depends on if you
can walk or take a trailer for a vehicle
trailer is between five and seven
thousand dollars for a person is the
trailer a better chances that they will
make it uh successfully across into the
united states see ya and trailer is much
better and more secure because it's a
long way to walk it takes around eight
hours a walk for three
in terms of
the business overall smuggling business
how
profitable
is that business
we make a lot of money i don't
understand how people sell their houses
and everything to get to the american
dream
i do it mostly to help people but yes we
earn a lot of money
are you worried about your safety
because
of cartels being involved in control of
people crossing
the cartels ask us for money and they
give us a coat and they take care of us
and that's how we take care of people
here
actually ramus is very safe because we
work with cartels and nothing happens to
people
how exactly are the cartels making it
safer
uh to cross the border
the cartels put like a guide that goes
on the way with the immigrants and i
keep an eye that the police isn't around
and in case there is dangers we return
and don't let anything happen to the
immigrating people they take care of
them
there is
a perception that
moving humans now across the border is
more profitable than even moving drugs
for for cartel business
yes people give more money right now
because the border is very controlled
with the drugs
i don't know much about it because i
just smuggled people but i know that
it's very controlled i know that some
people have spent between 15 to 20 000
to get into the united states
with business
this good
will this ever stop
no it's not going to stop if people need
money they're going to do anything to
get the money so no it's not going to
stop
you guys
on this side of the border
are you smarter
and better at this than the american
border patrol in their side
well it's a fight because we're younger
and we walk more the border patrol are
with their dogs in their cars but they
do hide well
sometimes they see migrants with cameras
and let them walk
then border patrol appears
i want to cross tonight
and i can pay
whatever you want to pay
what would be
the way you would send me
to
across the river or to the trailer how
would you send me
el primer
i will send you in a trailer in eight
hours you'll arrive in houston but you
have to go through the river from the
river you have to walk once you cross
you walk and then they pick you up
from there they can take you another
part let's say a walmart and from
walmart they take you to a house in the
house you wait for your turn and trailer
again and into the united states
and jillian it's really a remarkable
interview because we've been working for
more than better part of a year with
moira patterson my mexican fixer she is
such an amazing producer and individual
she met with individuals in mexico city
to make this happen in tapachula where
we were
this past year but finally he went on
camera and the only reason why we can
figure out that he was willing to go on
camera is because the cartels are so
brazen so bold so aware of how much
control they had they were willing to
tell us about it